[Música]
vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Rosa Pérez mateu Rosa Buen día para
usted Buen día Ángela está muy
interesante su segmento de hoy vamos a
empezar con la exclusiva del Washington
post sobre el globo chino que sería
parte de un vasto programa de vigilancia
aérea según Estados Unidos exactamente y
como bien dices no es una exclusiva de
los Washington post firmada por illing
harrisson y dan lamozi que replican
otros medios de comunicación como la
doce bl que estamos viendo aquí detrás
bien esta información proviene
supuestamente de la inteligencia de
Estados Unidos y ha sido comentada
filtrada a los periodistas del
Washington post a través de funcionarios
que mantienen su condición de anonimato
y que aseguran que estos supuestos
globos espía que recordemos de China que
recordemos que china reivindica como de
uso civil estarían sin embargo
vinculados con una supuesto programa del
ejército de China a gran escala que
estaría basado en la provincia de janean
en la isla del mar de la China
meridional y que operaría este programa
de vigilancia masiva desde hace varios
años recabando información militar desde
países o de áreas que son de interés
para las autoridades de Beijing como
Taiwán Vietnam Japón India o filipinas
Estos son algunos de los ejemplos que
nos da este artículo pero que asegura
sin embargo que estos globos habrían
sobrevolado y habrían sido detectados en
los cinco continentes bien la
información como suele pasar con este
tipo de artículos basados en comentarios
de personas que se mantienen en
anonimato no y en información de
inteligencia son un poco ambiguas no
todas estas afirmaciones Por ejemplo nos
dice este texto que no saben el tamaño
exacto de este despliegue de este
programa Pero afirma también este texto
que habrían tenido lugar decenas no de
misiones desde 2018 no sabemos por qué
exactamente citan 2018 En todo caso
acaba el artículo señalando que Estados
Unidos ya ha empezado a compartir esta
información sobre este supuesto programa
masivo de espionaje militar chino con a
sus distintas embajadas a lo ancho y
largo del planeta y con sus países
aliados Rosa ahora vamos a pasar al tema
que venimos manejando desde anoche el
medio político hace un análisis el
discurso del estado de la Unión de Joe
biden y tiene este particular título lo
que vaiden dijo y lo que quería decir
exactamente y el medio político intenta
leer un poco entre líneas las citas
textuales no pronunciadas ayer por Joe
biden en una discurso que dice se centró
en los intereses bipartidistas y en a
los intereses no de Unión nacional en un
momento en plena discusión sobre si se
representará a la elección de Cara a las
presidenciales de 2024 empezamos con un
extracto no que se llama pues bueno lo
titulan con el nombre de Kevin mccarthy
no presidente de la cámara de
representantes y cogen la cita textual
como decíamos y hacen el análisis de lo
que se podría extraer entre líneas la
cita textual es cuando él felicitó a la
republicano que venga macarthy y a los
nuevos miembros del Congreso de esta
legislatura ya 118 de Estados Unidos y
dijo que estaba deseando trabajar juntos
dice sin embargo lo que quería decir
según el análisis de político es estos
van a ser dos años bien largos señala
político biden cree en los pactos
bipartidistas para llevar a cabo ciertas
políticas pero sabe que la mayoría
republicana en la cámara va a centrarse
en dañar lo políticamente y a
debilitarlo de Cara a la reelección otro
tema titulado yo biden versus Trump no
dice dos años atrás nuestra economía se
tambaleaba esto es la cita textual de
biden Nosotros hemos creado un récord de
12 millones de empleos hace dos años el
covid cerro nuestros negocios escuelas
ahora el covid ya no controla nuestras
vidas hace dos años nuestra democracia
enfrentaba la mayor amenaza desde la
guerra civil hoy aunque herida nuestra
democracia permanece inquebrantable sin
embargo según los periodistas de
político dicen lo que realmente vaiden
quiso decir es alguien recuerda 2020 el
caos con Donald Trump realmente quieren
volver a eso
pues vamos a seguir ahondando en este
discurso que francamente rosa para ser
tan esperado estuvo muy centrado en
política interna y hubo muchos temas que
se quedaron en el aire como el de los
Globos espía de China Pero bueno
precisamente el New York Times hace un
de algunos de los puntos del discurso
cuéntenos exactamente y los califica
como verdad o esto necesita contexto la
verdad no encontramos ninguno que haya
sido calificado por los periodistas del
New York Times como falso Pero sí hay
bastantes con falta de pruebas Bueno
concretamente hay uno con falta de
pruebas y varios con falta de contexto
rápidamente el de falta de pruebas es en
los últimos dos años las democracias se
han fortalecido y las autocracias se han
debilitado los periodistas que no hay
evidencia de esto y por ejemplo esto
necesita contexto cuando dijo que ha
creado más empleos en dos años que
cualquier presidente en cuatro años dice
esto es verdad en términos absolutos sin
embargo es matizable en términos
relativos de esto vamos a hablar más
adelante con nuestro invitado del día de
hecho después de usted pero vamos a
hacer el cierre con otra noticia Que es
bien importante sobre todo para los
fanáticos del baloncesto y son los
titulares dedicados al jugador de los
Lakers el LeBron James que batió récords
exactamente y hemos querido seleccionar
el columbuspacho en medio de Ohio el
estado natal de Lebron James que dijo
rápidamente llegó el momento para Lebron
James anoche de este martes el niño de
acron a su ciudad natal no quería
esperar una noche más para convertirse
en el mayor anotador de la historia de
la NBA tenemos NBA maniacs que dice el 7
de febrero de 2023 quedará grabado
Eternamente en los libros dorados de la
NBA o el marca no este medio deportivo
que dice ese chico que ya era una
estrella con 17 años pasa a la leyenda
al terreno que sobrepasa los números los
títulos el terreno del para siempre una
locura Gracias Rosa a usted a ti Ángela
hasta mañana